[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey i know this is oh boy that's loud um
this is a cold open here today just
wanted to talk with you really quickly
before we go into the open and before we
go into the show i think we're gonna
have rudy giuliani in the show
uh
look
every now and then when we get to do
this show
we get to do it
and i mean that even though this is a
very dark day in american history
we get to do this with you we get to
experience it with you this is one of
those
days
that you're going to remember
for the rest of your life this is one of
those days that you're going to be
telling your children about your
grandchildren about this is
a line that has been crossed
a bell that has been rung that can't be
unrung and let me just tell you this
before we move on today we're going to
get into what we know there's a lot of
misinformation out there
both sides largely from the left and
mainstream media
uh we'll get into what the fbi is doing
what the fbi is not doing but before any
of that
last night i thought about uh
you know doing a video on instagram
something while this was happening or
going to a live stream in that moment
because we've done that in the past
i was conflicted
and let me explain to you what i mean um
you're mad
i'm mad
you're pissed
rightfully so
but you don't want to make decisions at
that point
you want to make decisions that are
measured and appropriate
and you don't want to interrupt your
enemy while they're making a mistake so
that's what i was thinking about
and then i started thinking about okay
strategy what does this mean obviously
this is going to have some backlash uh
with the midterms
how should we couch our words i always
try and be pretty prudent with issues
like this
and then i found myself at the
crossroads
of if you have children by the way they
shouldn't be watching the show today
uh at the crossroads of i don't care and
[ __ ] you
this is so wrong so tyrannical there
needs to be a hill that you're willing
to die on
this is it now i don't mean literally
i'm not calling you to violence unlike
what's being implied on twitter eric
swalwell with a fight like hell
banging chinese spies
um
you're mad
now we don't need to make our decisions
right now we do need to wait for some
information to come out but the world
needs to see that half of this country
is pissed i'm not saying make executive
decisions while you're pissed but we all
need to hit the purge button
and the world needs to see you hit the
purge button and we get to hit the purge
button with you so
i reserve the right to change my mind on
some things that i say today i reserve
the right with new information to maybe
change tact
but
today is the day that we all have the
right
to be pissed off to yell to scream to
behave not as egregiously as the left
but it's time to fight fire a little bit
with fire today we're also going to get
into i was really spending all night and
i didn't sleep much thinking about what
is it that i can do what is that we can
do here or we can offer you
quantifiable steps
that you can take
and some of those are going to have to
be addressed on mug club not on youtube
not because it's a call for violence not
because it's a call for
a physical civil war
but because i don't know the rule book
and i know that they're on high alert
over there at youtube
we have an inside skinny on that
and before we get to anything else and
we're going to get into the show here
today and hopefully have some fun with
it as well because i understand that's a
big reason why you tune in
let's just dispel of this idea
right on the outset that oh this is a
trump appointee to the fbi sure oh this
is a trump appointee the the judge
maybe we'll get into that garland had to
sign off on this
so
that's what you were saying that's what
they've been saying on cnn all morning
msnbc
all the mainstream outlets
look
this is just like the issue we discussed
yesterday with the irs
it's about job security
do you mean to tell me that every single
employee at your company looks out for
the best interest of the boss who hired
them
it could not be less relevant
it doesn't matter
if they were appointed by president
trump they can also betray people these
are people in government entrenched who
value their job security and their
benefits
over
your right to freedom
and and here's something else
yeah we need to be prudent we need to be
measured but there's a reason that you
should be mad and there's by the way
i wish i could say i bring you tidings
of great joy
i think there is a silver lining we'll
get into that there's a reason that you
feel scared and you should be there's
nowhere else to go let's be clear there
is nowhere else
for this administration
for these intelligence agencies to go
other than to conveniently use the
radical expansion of the irs to do this
to you
that's their only next step what else
can they do
beyond going in door to door like
gestapo and taking your guns right like
they
did in places like australia sorry
mandatory buy back beyond the actual
physical violence
there's nowhere else for them to go
other than to do this to other people
and they've already taken measures
yesterday
with amendments and a process that was
done in the dead of night in secret
rooms so that you can be audited you can
be prosecuted your house can be raided
and by the way
it's happened to a lot of people sure
it's happened to james o'keefe you may
not be familiar with what happened with
us in the fbi we'll get into that
it's okay to be mad it's okay to be
scared
i am
everyone in the united states and if the
left understood what this meant
they would all be scared too
because this goes both ways and for the
first time
that i've advocated on the show it
should go both ways
you can unring that bell the next
president of the united states
needs to prosecute
everyone
needs to clean house everywhere and i
will tell you this we'll get into this
here's a purity test for you
any republican who does not actively
right now within the next what time is
it
10 18 eastern
by noon today
any republican
right now in office are running for
office who does not actively champion
the defunding the dismantling
of our intelligence agencies
i will not vote for
don't care who it is
are you listening ted cruz are you
listening to santas are you listening
rubio
are you listening no
the term skeleton crew
should be a generous application to what
the fbi
will be
when the next president is through with
him this is not about backing the blue
it's not about guys with guns it's about
guys with pencils it's about buttersoft
[ __ ] with clip-on ties who are just
taking orders just doing their job well
guess what
i know the people who are having you do
this have promised that they'll kill you
last figuratively
that's never how it works out
so
the extremes the bill crystals of the
world the lincoln projects the i'm the
good republican no you're not you're
complicit with evil
and any republican and any host
anyone who claims to put on our team
jersey
and doesn't actively advocate for the
dismantling
dismembering
complete restructuring if at all
of all of our intelligence agencies
there is a special place in hell for
people like you it's one thing
to wear the jersey of evil it's another
to try and link arms with us and then
turn on us
how's that for purity test i'm pissed
this show's gonna be
different tenor and tone are you
starting to get the picture on with the
show
get ready for now that's what i call
trump in this compilation your favorite
president makes these hits his own don't
go chasing gdp
the
it comes a better metric and who can
forget the pete butt king song splish
splash they were taking a bath
and it was a couple of
eggs
voted on by the attendees at the weekly
white house talent show this collection
is sure to make you want to get up and
dance nikki don't lose my number
might replace pets with someone else
i might
i haven't decided support the police
because they work really really hard
news
it's all fake news
p-i-g-c
that's how you spell hillary b-i-g-c
senator for hillary welcome to the
hulk california
there's a homeless face
poop all over the place
lots of poop now that's what i call
trump
now that's why i called him the day one
season called 1800 2024
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
yeah there's a sip what the hell's the
difference
[Laughter]
uh we have a poll up on twitter if we
should completely abolish the fbi i
don't know if we can do polls on twitter
but that's my question of the day to you
you can do you think the fbi should
still be a thing comment below
it's a leading question
i don't care i'm not a lawyer
now there's a judge who signed off on
this by the way necessarily it was but
then you know singing
uh epstein can i get some epstein here
it's a live show monday through thursday
that's the best way to support that's
the best way to watch
go to rumble go to mug club livestream
mug club we have i believe rudy giuliani
in the show we'll be doing an extended
interview today uh there's the podcast
if you're on spotify if you're on apple
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
because god only knows how long we'll be
here yeah we're on youtube right now i
don't really care uh okay
are you pissed yeah i'm pretty i'm i'm
pissed i'm pissed and you know what it's
okay be pissed with us we're going to be
doing extended chat too by the way on
mug club the reason we don't do chat on
youtube well a couple of things first
off we do it with mug club exclusively
because these people actually uh support
and they deserve that perk also
you can be held liable for the crazy
crap that people say on youtube and chat
and i don't really want to deal with it
it's a fair point gerald how are you i
am i'm pissed as well yeah i'm pissed as
well but you know
fight like hell man everything's coming
in a little bit loud but you're coming
in i think it could just be my headphone
volume and uh i'm on tour with him uh in
the lettuce crowd.com tour september
16th 17th uh we were in charleston west
virginia on october 8th but uh you know
what today's not really about that how
are you mr dave landau ahoy i'm good i
uh i uh died yeah yeah eric swalwell has
sex with chinese spies he does that's a
fact unprotected i'll be in fort wayne
at the end of august that's a fact and
eric swalwell uh
has sex with chinese spy yes yeah isn't
it weird isn't it weird when you fall
into this
cosmic bunny hole where you're like eric
swalwell gets to criticize me on twitter
i just saw that and i kept thinking
didn't you give information to chinese
spies while you were having sex with
right well maybe it was before it was
before i don't know
it was during it was payment for
services it could have been whispering
in her ear while he was having sex with
chinese spies yeah reconciliation
actually i think i've done my
constituents bidding i don't know
anything yeah
well that's true
oh i mean he may not know much yeah but
whatever little he knew he shared with a
chinese spy he's the radio of
representatives he is
that's a good one now
mr radio goes to washington
shopping cart so you know this monday
night
uh president trump released a statement
that federal agents raided the estate at
mar-a-lago now we have some new
information
and i also think there's some context
that's important here that a lot of
other people are going to
probably miss we have what the fbi has
been busy not doing right because of
what they've been busy doing
and i want this to be a reference piece
for you
i want you to be able to reference this
episode
whenever you say uh hold on what was it
that what was it the fbi was doing whose
houses did they raid what warrants did
they not serve
i'm doing my best to include all of that
here uh today for you but let me read a
statement here
uh from uh president trump says these
are dark times for our nation it's my
beautiful home mar-a-lago in palm beach
florida is currently under siege rated
occupied by a large group of fbi agents
it's prosecute prosecutorial misconduct
weaponization of the justice system an
attack
look you already know this okay
and this is why um
we need to fight like hell by the way
you can go you can go to the shop it's
just it's not about them if you don't
want to buy the merch it's just this is
a this is about putting on a team jersey
so people know where you stand actually
the one you have and the one dave has is
probably better the george washington
one right it's about solid area you see
something you know where they stand it's
like half a christian fish drawn in the
sand
the triangle part uh yeah i don't know
it's a curve
i can't do i don't have a protractor
there you go they took mine at the
airport
oh they're really strict about that
so last night i tweeted this out really
quickly just so you can see the
weaponization that's going to take place
against you
tomorrow's worst sleep well eric swabble
decided to chime in
here he is
laughing the only world shows yeah
that's also what the chinese spy did
after he she had sex with him yeah well
she did it when he took off his pants
[Laughter]
she's like in my country they're even
even bigger you do foot binding on penis
so uh the fbi agents they obtained a
search warrant okay
from a federal magistrate judge in west
palm beach okay the west palm beach
location of the us district court for
the southern district of florida has
three magistrates
i know some of you're thinking from
role-playing games you're like what is
that no they get a mage
thank judge as bruce rinehart william
matthewman
ryan mccabe
august 5th the warrant was uh assigned
to the application was assigned to
reinhardt now let me give you a little
bit of history on this judge because
people are saying oh this judge must be
a as a trump guy doesn't matter
people turn on people all the time
we know that garland would have had to
sign off on this we know that ray would
have had to know about this that's what
we did know this morning for sure and
just about 10 minutes ago we were able
to confirm this because there was a lot
of information circulating not all of it
correct i want to make sure that
everything i bring you today is correct
and we have done our best we have great
researchers on it right now producers
making sure to double check crossrt's
daughter i so reinhardt quit his job as
u.s attorney
to defend jeffrey epstein's clients in
2008
insuring
all but insuring that's a nice way of
saying insuring yeah
immunity for sex trafficking yeah
federal immunity oh so that predators
still walk among us yes oh cool
basically and the in the most
interesting part of this is that he
started an llc prior to leaving listed
his primary address for this business as
epstein's lead counsel's office and is
that panel vans llc yes
candy and puppies yes that is
interesting bed sheet rope
absolutely security camera jammers
incorporated yeah yeah prisoner pinatas
yes llc
well the good news is we have a bunch of
new irs agents who could audit it well
that's true yes right maybe maybe a step
taken
that's me holding my breath yeah that's
pantomiming something that'll never
happen time to audit child grave well
look and the one of the reasons that
this matters is because every single
media outlet right now is saying wow
they must have had so much evidence to
be able to obtain that and i'm like i
i don't trust these people well this guy
also donated to obama and of course i
repeat myself jeb bush presidential
campaign obama light basically yeah no
so donald trump appointed judge this is
what all these people are going after
trump and these are his friends this is
a guy who defended epstein and a guy who
donated to both the obama and jeb bush
presidential campaigns yeah let's be
clear about this and people want to say
oh talk about epstein what about trump
as soon as trump found out about epstein
being creepy he kicked him out
permanently yeah from mar-a-lago done
are you to be blamed if you've ever been
friends with somebody who ever been
acquaintances with somebody before you
found out that they're a criminal or a
sex offender or even before he was
prosecuted just kind of creepy general
malfeasance trump said you're outta here
yeah exactly and by the way you have to
if you were one of those people that
believe oh this is totally above board
do you really think everything that's
gone on with the epstein trial was
totally above board i'm not even talking
about his suicide on accident um what
i'm talking about is that none of these
people
that he implicated
or could have implicated have ever been
put on a list and brought before a judge
right none of them
they flew on planes we have records of
them taking flights we have photographs
we have lawsuits settled in the uk
against royalty
none of the people in the united states
that knew epstein and hung out with them
on a regular basis and were connected to
the clintons ever including the clintons
ever get brought before a judge that's
the same guy including bill who we
know there's public information that we
know let go of his security detail while
on the island well that's fine i mean
it's okay no 28 was it 26 or was it 27
flights i don't know but he had a
frequent flyer passes
to the right executive platinum yeah
they call your name and then everybody
else just has to stand aside
he kept getting upgraded which is
actually a lower age yeah that's it yeah
it's true no i don't it's a really weird
system yes it's what they call platinum
status yes yeah the fastpass and he was
only kicked off the lead express because
he took a dump in the bathroom well
that's poor form can't do that never on
a plane
i have a friend who did that with a very
famous man who had a jet and the
bathroom didn't work and he used it he
only found out afterwards and he was no
longer allowed on it well it's not his
fault i'll tell you off air who it was
oh well he farts on mike yes he does
like he poops on planes uh wouldn't
surprise me at all nothing would
surprise me about swollen hey swalwell
come on the show buddy yeah we should
talk come laugh you laughed come laugh
with us i'm on the show champ have a
laugh come have some farts and giggles
yeah
come on show them come on show me show
me my place they're uh they're chief
put me in my place i'm just a silly old
comedian host of a show on youtube you
know who what i mean come on you're a
united states representative
you should make quick work of me all
right representative for china yes well
well you know we're splitting hairs true
you say tomato i say ting alfa true now
plenty of americans of course just so
you know you're not alone i've already
taken the streets in palm beach to
support president trump here you go
[Music]
[Music]
now let me get into something that we uh
we
have been told okay and then let me show
you a clip that shows uh that shows
beyond any shadow of a doubt that it's
at the very least opaque yeah
so this comes from the washington post
all references available at la
rescher.com we've primarily tried to use
leftist sources today so that you know
we're not accused of you know providing
information that you don't like
reportedly the justice department they
say that they've been investigating the
potential mishandling of classified
material oh no after this is a quote the
national archives and records
administration said it had retrieved
from mar-a-lago 15 boxes of records
containing classified information
earlier this year so a couple of things
here
that's what they're saying
but these are the people who remember
also said there was the pis the p tape
donald trump and prostitutes peeing
remember on the laminated furniture uh
remember there was also there was the
n-word christmas reel from apprentice
the b-roll that never made it out
the russian collusion documents
so now these people are saying there
could be potential mishandling of
classified now let's be really clear
because you will see this all over
twitter all over instagram all over
youtube and probably on cnn from people
who don't know their thumb from their
dick
saying he doesn't have right to classify
material of course he does jimmy carter
released he declassified information
after his presidency that that happens
all the time they're not saying
that a
former president
if you want to use that term
doesn't have the right to classify
material they're saying that he
mishandled okay classified material so
anyone who says an ex-president does not
have the right to classify material
doesn't know what they're talking about
and that's not even what they're
alleging they're hoping that they make
it opaque enough that enough people out
there the little monkey foot soldiers go
out and say you shouldn't have access to
classified material and by the way i i
know everyone's doing the yeah what
about isn't with hillary clinton here's
the thing donald trump was president
hillary clinton wasn't her only
qualification was that she was the only
[ __ ] not screwing the president and
it's not that she had classified
material it's that she deleted
classified material bleached i believe
bleached bleached but if you're looking
for piss tapes and russians why don't
you just look at hunter's laptop that's
a good point that'd be a good place or
just look at uh well if you want you
know chinese you just go swa wells
that's true ring footage yes
his fart box yes
it's awesome devil is a scream box just
the sequence matters
now investigators
i'm still a child i'm mad but i'm still
a child
uh they were allegedly aware of the
documents in trump's possession
and just told him that
they needed to be
secured better that might be
all the mishandling that had taken place
here's a clip investigators went down to
mar-a-lago and actually met with trump's
attorneys we are told it was back in
early june they believe and they met
with trump's attorneys i am told that
they were shown a room that had boxes of
documents that were there that day
they sent a letter to trump's attorneys
asking them to further secure the room
it tells you that they have concerns
about how that information that material
those boxes of documents we're going to
continue to be um respected and used by
his wife
and his staff and it may be as caitlyn
points out mentally that they weren't
satisfied with the security of the room
that they weren't satisfied with the
level of cooperation
so they took the extraordinary step of
going to a federal judge who has to
authorize a search warrant and and you
have the events that we've had over the
last 24 hours
if that is the justification that we
were unsatisfied with how he secured the
documents and you just threw out 250
plus years of precedent or precedence
whichever one will have bill on to tell
us which one that is that is insane and
by the way they actually broke into his
safe they opened up his safe is that is
that not a secure area i was frankly
surprised that president trump was as
responsible as he was with the storage
i'm surprised he wasn't using them as
coasters for his diet coke cans by the
hot tub i'm not even lying so i believe
he's such a wheeling and dealing guy i
didn't think he would be that prudent
i thought he would have gone to
creighton barrel yes so the container
store perhaps which i don't know what
that store is like do you only sell
containers your whole store is the you
store i've never walked in
i think it's just cheap coffins yeah
cough truck
sound like a teenager in the system
you're like i've never walked in the fat
guy wants to see the movie
what's that talking about our
researchers just sent a pretty
surprising tweet from andrew cuomo okay
uh do you just wait hold on a second
this is the cuomo who covered up the
nursing home death right this is the
cuomo who actually enacted policies that
led to thousands of deaths and his place
wasn't rated because it would have been
who needs that many barbells and
evidence sexual misconduct as well yes
yeah good point dave yeah i forgot about
that admitted okay sorry go ahead yeah
so he said doj must immediately explain
the reason for its raid and it must be
more than a search for inconsequential
archives or it will be viewed as a
political tactic and undermine any
future credible investigation and
legitimacy of january 6 investigations
oh good for him except for the last part
yeah exactly
please don't investigate me yes
because there's too much we do we
we don't want to be just
we don't want to be bickering about who
investigate so
if i was him i would not have opened my
mouth no if they're not investigating
you just don't say a word be like oh
thank god they're investigating trump
otherwise i would be on the dot i mean i
appreciate he's trying to act as those
as though he's being consistent but uh
you know what i think that when you
actually enact policies that lead to the
deaths and lie about it maybe you should
be investigated not saying they should
rage your house but maybe force you to
answer questions god forbid him and
governor whitmer so um when it has
document storage is of course they need
probable cause to issue a warrant and uh
senate minority leader kevin mccarthy
said that he's seen enough the
department of justice has reached an
intolerable state of weaponized
politicians attorney general garland
preserve your documents and clear your
calendar i love that
um
okay
we're going to have some more
information here some more research as
it comes in and i know gerald has some
interesting points
this is a lot of you may be feeling in
your gut
and not necessarily
fully aware of how to articulate
the fear that you have we all know that
the intelligence agencies are being used
as political arms of this administration
but we need to be able to put a finer
point on it you need to be able to argue
it with other people
so let me break this down for you
we told you about all the claims that
the intelligence agencies made as it
related to pissing tapes as it related
to russian collusion right anywhere else
you'd be fired
sure anywhere else let me add to that
what the what we know the fbi is not
doing
okay
dr larry they're not investigating dr
larry nassar
remember
the fbi provided completely inaccurate
and complete information this is the guy
who systematically sexually abused
the female gymnastics team fairness it
was for years hundreds of allegations so
only hundreds it was bill cosby times
four right that's all
that's collage b over there token on uh
we know that they weren't investigating
him
ineptitude or selective prosecution all
right hunter biden
we know the fbi's not been investigating
hunter biden tax violations of course
the illegal firearm purchased throwing
it in a trash bin outside of a school
yes
solicitation drugs corruption not to
mention his direct implication of his
father in said illegal activities
i don't know how much of a crime it is
to be banging your niece if she's of age
at the very least it's gross very gross
so not larry nasser lewis not larry
nasser not hunter biden
hey what about questioning ashley biden
because again we have it's people will
say hunter biden's not president well
hold on a second he is the son of a
sitting president that's an incredible
liability
and he implicated the
sitting former vice president
not only did he we have cooperation from
ashley biden the diary where she talked
about being molested she talked about at
the very least inappropriate showers
with her father i don't think
and by that i mean i know they didn't
bring her in for questioning not saying
they should have raided ashley biden's
home but by this standard they should
have absolutely raided hunter biden
should have absolutely been raiding
larry nassar immediately far sooner than
you knew about it
but they should at least have brought
ashley biden in for questioning no
instead what the rate of james o'keefe
instead for having the diary priorities
our good old favorite eric swalwell we
know the fbi is not rating eric swalwell
who was having sex with chinese spies
and i understand it he's desperate well
i mean come on didn't he date a russian
like right after two
yeah you know
it's he is
i don't think so much he doesn't have a
fetish for spies so much as he'll
exclusively fornicate with communists
yes well that's true ah yeah he had a
role play as ivan drakov and spies
yes
x wobble no no raid
what about paul pelosi hmm what about
paul pelosi what about the pelosi's in
general what about the insider trading
what about the wealth exponentially
increasing
through deals
coincidence well he just yes coincidence
sorry i have to be careful with youtube
he raids his belly with liquor then gets
behind the wheel yes he does yes just
like uh uh uh was it harry reid's
brother larry reid for those who don't
remember harry reid and larry got into a
bar fight together and then he claimed
that he got hurt in the bathroom
harry and larry brothers had a drunken
brawl he beat his ass it's the funniest
story i've ever heard in my life and you
probably don't know about it
your other brother mo was in the car
yeah
cousin shemp only came in later and he
was people mostly forgot about that
um
we know the fbi wasn't investigating
epstein's
clients from his little black book huh
interesting
not a single person has been brought in
as of this broadcast yeah they weren't
making sure that the video feed in the
cell worked or that the guards knew not
to leave him with the ability to
hang himself right wellinges lane is
horribly punished at a prison where they
allow yoga yes yes with goats i hear
yeah
rough yoga they stand on your back it's
really liberal is that an actual thing i
thought you meant like greatest of all
time yoga or you mean actually no goat
yoga no she's in a very comfortable uh
jail where only vegan food you might
have secrets on people yeah yeah well i
hope they let her wear her outfit from
that prison with juicy written across
the back and then put her in a maximum
security penitentiary with transgender
inmates who by the way according to
youtube so i just want to be clear have
never sexually accomplished any female
inmates ever totally safe ever i'm now
pro male to female trans in jazlane
maxwell's prison
bang bang maxwell still they came right
down the taller stronger and angrier the
better yes
i want the white gorilla from congo
you want ron perlman i want ron perlman
to be her cell mate
in a wig
with a laser gun
we know the fbi is not investigating
governor cuomo we know that by his tweet
he's like please don't
for killing old people and lying about
it we know they haven't investigated a
rated governor whitmer
did the same thing by the way whitmer
death toll is still a thing you can go
check it out she still has an answer to
those fisa requests no i found an
interesting article too on what they're
not doing related to hunter biden yeah
you need to read it anything does the
article just read anything and article
the all right it doesn't end article
right so we've got a couple of overlays
here this is a letter from senator chuck
grassley it'll take me just a second
he's talking
once can you pause one second because
joseph uh biden joseph r biden
is his middle name i don't think i'm
joseph
i know that's right but i just joseph r
biden
you're gonna hate the way you look
is now today not talking about this his
uh his approach is the hogan's heroes i
know nothing he's talking about a bill
to increase chip manufacturing not a
moment too soon with those missiles
being fired toward taiwan let's see what
he's saying on one of the darkest days
in american history as it relates to
your personal freedom it looks like iron
deficiency man
years and years
calling for instead of a nuclear power
it's just a pacemaker
you help make it happen
you represent why
we are better positioned than any any
other nation in the world better
business economic competition did he
just say pez is he requesting a pez
dispenser someone get that man a pez
dispenser
everybody wants to invest in the
business of pez that's a pesnes by the
way jack nicholson used to wear
sunglasses all the time because he was
on drugs he's wearing them because his
eyes are no longer there and dimension
drugs
it's just holes
just a bowling ball with teeth all right
so just so you see right now and cnn is
covering this this is hey hey we're
going to increase uh we're going to
increase chipsets in the united states
that's good right people are going what
about the prosecutorial misconduct what
about our rights the irs
rating of former presidents should we be
talking about that i want to make sure
we go back to this live on some channel
when they start asking questions you
know the questions are not going to have
anything to do with chips yeah and he's
not going to take a single one of them
he may trip and fall trying to run away
yeah we'll see how that goes
but so a couple of things this i just
thought he just said that she can't eat
just one he doesn't know where he is go
with you no he said but wait
if you act now
sorry just off of his
your no eyes yeah just the idea of
takeovers aviators and it's just like
ghosts screaming like the door knocker
and a jiminy crickets christmas
it just takes them on painted on other
aviators yeah just just a series of
nesting dollars
all right go ahead and read your
articles i want to get to what the fbi
is doing
so you're going to get to what the fbi
is investigating this is what the fbi is
doing to to not investigate the hunter
biden story and to make sure none of us
do so i'll read it take just a second
first it's been alleged this is grassley
saying this first it's been alleged the
fbi developed information in 2020 about
hunter biden criminal financial and
related activity it's further alleged in
august 2020 fbi supervisory intelligence
analyst blah blah used fbi headquarters
team to improperly discredit negative
hunter biden information as
disinformation and caused investigative
activity to cease basically the fbi said
this is misinformation when they knew it
wasn't right it was falsely labeled and
what he said is it's verified
information and easily verifiable
information that was discredited as
false the next one is even worse for me
they came and actually gave them a
briefing during their investigation the
fbi came and it was unsolicited briefing
and it was a so you know
briefing right exactly irrelevant
briefing
and all of the information from that
briefing was later leaked to discredit
the investigation right and then pelosi
schumer
uh there are a couple of other people
signed on to this nancy pelosi uh mark
warner and then adam schiff came out and
said and used that information to
discredit the investigation and say that
the congress is actually being used by
russia for disinformation against hunter
biden yeah and then they rated giuliani
by the way claiming that he stole the
laptop once they realized it was real so
it went from it's not real it's fake
it's wrestling just information too yeah
the laptop was stolen to uh the geek
squad guy the guy from the computer
repair shop is a russian plant too in
other words they constantly change the
story so long as it allows them their
grasp on power it's not about
prosecuting donald trump it's about
being able to prosecute you that's why
they want to increase the irs it's not
about letting hunter biden off the hook
it's about letting joe biden off the
hook it's not letting hillary clinton
off hook if i've always said i've said
this repeatedly it's not are we a
country of laws are the laws applied
equally
if they aren't
then there's no then the laws are are
valueless right and the team that
grassley has a problem with here
the white this was the same office that
issued
the uh the raid the carried out the raid
right carried out the right in florida
okay
so all right so the fbi not going after
larry nassar okay just to recap not
going after hunter biden didn't raid
them not even questioning ashley biden
eric swalwell banging chinese spies paul
pelosi insider training uh epstein black
book clients okay governor whitmer
governor cuomo why because the fbi's
been pretty busy with some other things
we can go back pretty let's go back to
2003 their uh questionable involvement
in the herald square bombing plot now
the reason that i'm setting that up for
you is because it brings us to newer
incidents where most of those involved
with these domestic terror plots or
kidnapping plots or assassination plots
were in fact fbi agents that's overlaid
b1 2010 barack obama's irs of course
targeted conservative groups affiliated
with the tea party movement right
boehner signed off on that
i'm done with that guy then in 2016
obama's fbi conducted surveillance fisa
surveillance on the trump campaign we
know that there's no doubt about it
remember
you were told that you were being
paranoid it was all a lie that was
circulated by who who who the fbi and
the doj who were doing it
then also in 2016 the propagation of the
fake steele dossier and the trump russia
hoax
the the reason for which he was
one of them impeached
then you have 2020 undercover fbi agents
who tricked michigan men into a
conspiracy to kidnap governor whitmer
and of course you have april uh 2021
they raided giuliani's apartment seized
cell phones and computers why and by the
way they left the laptop yeah they left
the laptop he's standing there holding
it with a sign that says hunter's laptop
and they go around him like world war z
he showed it to us on air for the first
time it was ever seen in public i
remember being shocked and the fbi said
no we don't want it
we want to find out we think it's more
dangerous for the american people that
you believe there's foul play in the
election right yeah then for the sitting
former vice president's son
to say 10 goes up to the big guy
and by the way something else that you
may not know
we have had our issues with the fbi
utah
2016
somewhere between 2016 and 2017. antifa
they were handing my producers uh ice
picks k
tasers you can see it all on video
for a ben shapiro rally i called ben
shapiro
i saved his life he owes me one
and i had the footage of them saying
we're going to get sawed off shotguns
too in our trunk for these people here
for the ben shapiro yeah uh speaking
event
i try to show it to the authorities they
had no interest there the local
authorities there was a reporter for 60
minutes who had no interest in it then
we were on the phone with the fbi
i said how did you get this information
we got on their encrypted app we right
we infiltrated antifa this is before
anyone else was even really trying to do
it we fell into this we just did our
best we said i'm shouldn't we be asking
you this question fbi
nothing happened no one did it by the
way some of those people who were on on
camera
were arrested that night
with the weapons that we filmed on
camera for assaulting conservatives at
the ben shapiro speaking event that
night
know the fbi did nothing
there's a man named jason chambers we've
talked about this
spoke with us for a long time after that
asking us questions kind of probing
there are some things that he brought up
that we thought was kind of thought
might be kind of weird disappeared off
the face of the earth never heard from
him again
he was involved with the plot to kidnap
governor whitmer remember when he was
asking us when we were going down to
michigan to host that rally and local
michigan news wrote about how oh
extremist groups showed up there first
they tried to say just like with the
hundred by the laptop they tried to say
only about two three hundred people
showed up to the michigan state capital
it was many many thousands of people
then they said it looks like there are
extremist groups there then
we had some probing questions about what
we were doing from people there at the
fbi i was like well we just actually
want to get the information on the
actual
death toll of nursing homes in michigan
because we know that they're inaccurate
and so we're encouraging everyone to
actually go to the website and issue
these fisa requests
or fire or a foia request for you
didn't hear from them again they were
more interested in faking conspiracies
to kidnap the governor
i bet you if we didn't cross our teas
and daughter eyes we could have been
hauled out in cuffs
we're doing things that you've seen
on air none of it's a secret
by the way rudy giuliani who i believe
is going to be in the show later yeah
10 15. still not in charge of the crime
just to be clear
let's continue with what the fbi is
doing we know what they're not doing
october 2021 uh garland directed
authorities to target angry parents at
school board meetings remember that
domestic terrorists domestic terrorists
because you don't want
your daughter in a bathroom
with teenage chicks with dicks
there's a legitimate purview of
the federal bureau of investigation
it's designed
to excuse criminals to let them off hook
and make criminals of you
oh wait a second do you have a concealed
carry permit we're going to expand our
ability to investigate you yeah mental
health checks well and it's really
upsetting that a father is pissed off
that his daughter was sexually accosted
in loudoun county in a bathroom by a boy
wearing a skirt yeah and that guy needs
to be taken you know take a look at him
you know what's not upsetting a man
sexually costing his niece ah hunter
biden
well the diary is upsetting yeah the
diarrhea that's upsetting
bridge too far of course james o'keefe
his apartment was raided
notice no one talks about the
inauthenticity of the ashley biden diary
he was never charged with a crime
hey liberals
you think they're not going to come for
you
and by the way i don't think that we
should be above
the fray
if republican gets in investigate
everybody raid everybody use all of it i
don't care if we become nicaragua at
this point you've already rung the bell
you can't unring it buttercup
here's something else that we know they
were doing in november 2021 uh the
whistleblower revealed that uh there was
a whistleblower revealed the the bureau
was investigating parents as domestic
terrorists
january 2022 former fbi director andrew
mccabe
compared mainstream conservatives to
terrorists and called for them to be
surveyed
of course let's not forget of the the
now i guess defunct misinformation board
by nina jankowicz because that one was
just they said well you know what this
one isn't a good look
and now of course this brings us just to
yesterday which you pointed out dave the
dems new spending bill democrats that
allows the irs to target the middle
class it says in their bill more
litigation more prosecution more
auditing
does this i mean when you at a certain
point you have to look at all of it add
it up and say wait a second this is all
about
not only power but selective enforcement
selective use of that power and
selective enforcement of the law all
references available at
lighterwithcrowder.com
it's not even up for it's not even up
for debate
[Music]
hey landlord do you know the worst part
of being on this balcony what's that
krondorf all the guns in this studio are
out of reach
it felt like a threat that felt like a
threat today of all days it's no longer
funny really really that wasn't even a
joke
they keep telling me to die yeah
how long are the season tickets
i think it's forever yeah they signed a
lifetime deal
they bought the balcony essentially i
should have read the fine print i know i
didn't i didn't even read it they built
the balcony okay it was supposed to be
an executive box so uh governor desantis
did sum this up pretty well he tweeted
out uh the rate of mar-a-lago is another
escalation in the website weaponization
of federal agencies against the regime's
political opponents while people like
hunter biden get treated with kid gloves
now the regime is getting another 87 000
irs agents to wield against adversaries
banana republic great it's one thing to
[ __ ] it's one thing to [ __ ]
defund the bastards
and [ __ ] i assume they have women
working there yeah stretching maternity
suits absolutely
you have to i mean you even said this if
you let it stay
you have to tear it down to the studs
it's cancer like it absolutely like this
place
the american people can no longer trust
that the fbi is going to do their job
and i'm sorry fbi agents out there who
are doing your job i know several of
them that are fantastic people
this is coming from the guys in
washington yeah this is coming and
they're filtering down to some of these
local field offices i don't know what to
do other than
to tear it down and rebuild and i'm sure
they want the same thing because this is
not the fbi that they joined this is not
the fbi that they wanted yeah maybe it
might be
down like j edgar hoover would another
man's pants yes exactly and by the way
just just think about this i know that
he did that i think i just like to wear
a dress just throw it out there everyone
so why he wanted to feel the air flow
yeah a little more comfortable i
understand i don't know he had a friend
with him all the time yeah well that's
different then
think about this who's the who is the
front runner right now for the
republican party
arguably who's the front runner donald
trump
we have joseph r biden who's saying he's
going to run for re-election so
essentially what just happened is this
he's going through this he's going to
fake a job
yes like someone who's
basement running down a main cross
street and doesn't want you to see that
they've quit so they kind of do the half
walk a little happen
so basically the sitting former vice
president who has declared his intention
to run again
his
fbi department of justice
have now
raided and investigated his primary
opponent yeah for the upcoming election
am i am i understanding this correctly
yes
by the way
in case you're looking to understand it
better cnn's got the scoop for you yeah
they're still covering that biden signed
a bipartisan chips and science 20
minutes it's an enormous amount of pork
in that bill too
mass does climate change in this are you
kidding me oh good we need more feel
like after 9 11 they're talking about a
fundraiser for a junior senator
after 9 11 they're talking about a new
kind of reese's buttercup yes
it's dark chocolate yes it's better for
you ooh there's a white chunk more
flavonoids what's all that smoke down
don't worry about it
it's halal too
[Laughter]
bad timing no not bad timing perfect
timing for cnn
no here's the thing and we're going to
have uh uh
former mayor giuliani on
and we'll go to mug club
bloodthirsty.com talk more about what it
is that you can do uh please like share
the show if you can
it helps and right now they are going to
label everything misinformation possibly
absolutely um
yeah there needs to be a purity test no
it needs to be a purity test for
republicans
for so-called conservatives i will not
vote for anyone who does not demand the
defunding of these intelligence agencies
period don't care who it is
won't vote for him
it's a gimme
it's a gimme right now
but beyond that
what can you do okay a couple of things
um
these people aren't your friend
people [ __ ] about division nope i'm
ready i want a thick dividing line
i really do it's time to start calling
offsides if uh
you're an at-will state and you're an
employer i would fire everybody
fire everybody who celebrates this
i would fire them just like maxine
waters said harass them wherever they go
and diners and well you know what don't
serve them
don't do business with them
people who want to destroy this republic
if we can keep it and your rights
are no longer your friend no more no
more barbecues with them no more
cocktail parties no more cocktails no
more tiffs treats
no treats
now there's a difference between people
who are let's say democrat voters for a
long time and saying this is beyond the
pale but people who celebrate this
i would at i'm not telling you what to
do i would advise you
to cut them from your life like a cancer
because they would celebrate the same if
it happened to you
don't serve them don't employ them don't
be nice with them don't work with them
and fight every single inch every single
time they say something where your
antenna goes up if they happen to be in
your periphery
go
that's [ __ ] call them on it
it's time to fight for every single
square inch name me an institution that
exists
in government
and by proxy of course the entertainment
industry media that has not been
overtaken by the left
public education
intelligence agencies military
health industry pharmaceutical
companies you can go to airlines you can
go to media you can go to hollywood
you guys can get uh someone who's there
in the map blaine you can get out of the
map i know i know giuliani's uh he's
he's popping in there some stuff about
julian
i know he's 15. 10 15 is when he is 10
15 when he comes on this is what you can
do in your own personal life i know not
everyone will agree with this you can
comment below if you agree with it i
have no interest in being friends with
these people none
none whatsoever
i think it's time to start fighting fire
with fire these are people who are
raiding
your homes who are going to audit your
friends and family who are harassing
your representatives
or intimidating people like larry elder
running for office into silence
you can't be ah gee gosh roy rogers this
thing and
be nice with him
we're past that
you guys want to [ __ ] about the
division all right
start clearing your own ranks i don't
want to see
the thing about
from eric swalwell is that's a man who
fears no retribution whatsoever yeah
it's like a woman who talks a bunch of
trash to some strange man she doesn't
know because she knows that he won't hit
her for the exact same reason he would
hit a man
it's the exact same thing it's eric
swellow going i was banging chinese
spies and they didn't raid my home
that's the problem i have with it not an
end zone dance i have a problem that
half of this country doesn't fear
retribution
we need to make them fear it and we need
to make the people who claim
to be championing our cause claim to be
carrying our mantle republicans
conservatives
they need to fear you not saying
violence i'm saying they need to fear
you
going on a campaign to remove any and
all of the power they so
desperately
desperately desire
or cling to
that's it that's it these are career
politicians you know you see what
happens you see what happens
with congressman you see what happens
with senators
right you see what happens with you saw
it with fouchy one of the highest-paid
officials in government a man who has
not worked in the private sector for
what do you think happens at the fbi
what do you think happens at doj at the
cia these are people who've worked there
their entire lives and are looking for a
pension
most of these people are totally fine
carrying out these marching orders so
long as they remain unaffected even if
they agree with you
if you work in these agents if you work
in these agencies now i got the dave
thing be a whistleblower yeah
everyone needs to fight every single
inch period don't look for a perfect
shot pressure pressure pressure pressure
pressure pressure pressure pressure in
your everyday life
resign yourself to every day for the
rest of your life
being uncomfortable
being uncomfortable because it's going
to be conflict that's okay
that's okay because peace is a two-way
street
they don't want it what do you mean they
are you othering yep they enemy left
democrats irs fbi doj
this administration
eric swalwell
enemies
not worthy adversaries not differing
points of view
are you starting to get the picture
let's say something dave
no no oh sorry okay
i think that i've gotten i said i got
the dave thing and i said what oh
that's all right i would
i just tried to let the moon slightly
yeah were they talking right now they're
talking about it real quickly they're
finally talking about on cnn good and
they have their most senior 16 year old
anchor on the job that's great one of
the fundraising texts that came out
overnight that was sent out by the
republican national committee it says
you know it calls this unprecedented it
is it says that it was biden's fbi rape
it is it
references the midterm saying it's time
to take back congress so this is a
familiar word that we've seen from
republicans um
in moments where former president trump
has come under fire especially found
himself in legal jeopardy um but but
fundraising off of this itself is fairly
unprecedented
holy [ __ ]
it's like let's say someone
someone raped and killed your whole
family is an extreme example to paint a
picture here yeah let's say someone
raped and killed your whole family and
hung them up upside down
from meat hooks like jose and kuze
hussein okay
and the media should be saying holy crap
this is unprecedented yeah
but you respond and say i'm gonna i'm
gonna beat this guy's ass they go that
kind of a response is unprecedented well
that you put out a reward for these guys
that's an oh my gosh
vigilante isn't much oh geez
the fact that he is raising camp is
unprecedented
really
that's the story
that's what you picked and it's a great
opportunity to start raising money yeah
yeah because they probably you know took
some of his cash as well from our largo
and uncle sam's none the wiser you know
why it's unprecedented
it hasn't happened in history by the way
there was another person who uh maybe
deserved it or at least some of his
cohorts the guy who uh you know oh nixon
yeah the guy who resigned on august 8th
that's weird the raid was conducted on
august 8th and it was the anniversary of
nixon i don't think there's any
connection there that means jfk is still
alive folks probably does and that ted
cruz's father didn't kill him well nixon
also said that the same people that uh
got jfk got him it was just that a
bullet would have been too obvious well
yes yeah
yeah unbelievable
i mean i i don't know where we go from
from here yeah well i know what you need
to do i don't know where we go from here
as a republic
unless
there's as much conflict as humanly
possible meaning between you and your
representatives and there does need to
be a purity test i do not mean right now
i'm not calling you to arms in a
physical civil war to be clear and by
the way if someone is doing that
glow worm that's why
you don't respond you don't
make your final executive decisions
right now but you start taking steps
yeah but i want everyone to see you mad
i don't think that enough hosts out
there i don't think that enough people
there are a few but a lot of them say
well this is wrong and says they talk
about it with this this distant
calculated cold
demeanor
that's not that's not me
that's not us here
whether it's kyle rittenhouse whether
it's this sorry i can't do it i only
know one way if you see me off there
people are often surprised like i feel
like i'm on the show pretty much
sometimes i'm a little quieter because
i'm tired if it's right after the show
these are the abcs of me and i think you
should let your freak flag fly yeah well
when donald trump said on january 6 that
if you if you don't fight like hell you
won't have a country you better fight
like hell he he wasn't calling people to
arms then either even though they've
tried to make you said make their voices
heard people think the voices heard
patriotically that's the catalyst for
all of this right as they said oh
january 6 investigation wait do you mean
you're you're talking about a plot to
overthrow the government from the same
speech where you said make your voices
heard patriotically and peacefully i
know you guys are going up to congress
to to make your voices heard not your
fists not your feet not weapons just
your voices heard but but he was
absolutely right think about this he was
telling you if you don't fight for your
country
if you don't fight to make sure that you
have the right representatives you don't
fight to make sure that you hold those
representatives accountable when they
start making changes if you don't do the
things like ron desantis did when he
fired the one of the prosecutors the
other day because he refused to enforce
the law if you don't do things like that
you won't have a country and so what are
you sitting around waiting for yeah you
won't have the country that you say that
you love and that gives you the freedoms
that you enjoy right now they'll just be
gone and the democrats don't
care
they want everything that you believe in
to be gone
well exactly what they want what i find
crazy is i i don't think i said on this
show we were discussing it before the
show but i was at hudson news on sunday
and then it's funny i was watching
hudson hawk on sunday really awful that
was fantastic i watched it every other
tuesday they don't have watches but hey
they sing songs i know it's crazy i uh
but i was at hudson news and uh the
cover of newsweek was will trump do time
and it was a picture of him in prison
and i thought wow i wonder what's going
to happen with trump
and then the next day
it was raided and it just shows how the
media creates the narrative or they have
information prior to anything happening
and it just it's very scary that
immediately that that's what happened
the next day like just that's i could
just see that and go oh that's weird i
wonder what's going to happen and within
not even 24 hours that's what happened
it's a surreal experience for example
when we had there were a few of them but
i remember because i was watching it
live senator hirono
yeah demanding
and complaining that i was not removed
from youtube for hate speech which
already the ceo of youtube said there
wasn't there was no violation of the
rules and i'm sitting there going
wait a second this is a sitting senator
not even from my district
demanding that i be removed and i will
tell you i'm always surprised that other
hosts aren't experiencing the same thing
if you're close to the target you're
going to have someone in the fbi trying
to sting you sorry we're just a bunch of
basic [ __ ] christian conservatives fbi
didn't have anything wish you did
sorry senator hirono it's not a
violation you watch it and you go
what world am i in you never expect this
you never expect this to happen and so
i'm acutely aware of it my biggest line
item
is legal fees outside of employees it's
payroll and then legal fees
those those are the most expensive line
items here in this company
because of the constant
ongoing battle
it's non-stop i mean it's it's it's
non-stop so i i understand but we're
fortunate enough and just to be clear
this show
before we bring on giuliani
um
it's not funded by billionaires
who made money off of energy it's not
funded by a 501c3 by non-profits no one
owns it but me
no one signs the front of the these
checks at this company but me 100 of it
and that is entirely funded by you and i
don't mean like pbs says it where they
say viewers like you but what they
really mean is it's actually receiving
countless untold federal grants
so if you want to go to
lightweightcredit.comclub you know you
can support it we're going to do another
uh
sorry i gotta bring up my ipad here
today is a little a little bit screwy
bear with me um
i'm going to be talking about stuff that
we probably probably can't talk on
youtube and i don't know that's the
thing too it's a constant game of it's
someone stepping back and laying down
landmines only there's no more land it's
just mines
hey hillary clinton found an opportunity
to capitalize off this if you want to
see that oh really oh by not having sex
with her husband
well that and every but her emails had
her shirt sold helps onward together
partners defend democracy build a
progressive bench and fight for our
values just saying by the way that is
the most retouched picture of hillary
clinton from the last year oh yeah what
is her she created an actual jawline
yeah it says but
yeah photoshopped this hat on me from
95. yeah yeah
it's just she she just merged it with
kate upton and thought it would be none
the wiser
that is unbelievable i i mean there's so
much more to come out on this i know
that the your husband raped somebody
yeah she's like i know
yeah she was trailer trash i was on the
island as well and by the way so you
said that
people are saying her butt her emails
right and pompeo came out and said this
he goes we knew that you had classified
information we knew it we proved it and
we didn't raid you and you said this is
the president yeah the bar is lower for
hillary
she would have had she wasn't even
president no no that's what she wasn't
even sleeping with the president the
bar's lower they would have had all the
right in the world to go after her i bet
her masseuse is the strongest person
alive yeah it's a swedish man named sven
yeah it just takes hours he goes he just
has two private clients john travolta
and her aunt that's true
they're insured like jlo's assets just
hillary clinton's ankles lloyd's of
london takes takes a lot of structural
integrity to keep this seizure ship up
yes
well he prefers travolta he finishes a
lot yeah exactly
well anyone would well yes
seen those dance moves
instead of massaging maxwell house
coffee cans hey flowers
you know it's hard to find those the tin
cans because i use them for ash trays
really yeah they're the best ash tray
because you put coffee grounds on you
close the lid you can't find the metal
the aluminum cans anymore i put the
cigarette plastic yeah yeah yeah hunter
with the crack pipe yeah do you think
hillary clinton's a lesbian i say yes
truthfully
yeah truthfully yes no i'm not joking i
think she's a lesbian yeah really yeah
yeah i think that's why she looks okay
her husband she's like like go do
whatever i did behind it was always an
arrangement he's like but i'm doing a 16
year old on epstein island ah have fun
she's like whatever whatever yeah i get
it make sure there's no cameras yeah and
he comes back uh i screwed up there were
cameras no there was actually someone
stenciling me in a dress you didn't have
to sit for the portrait i know three
hours it was a thing i thought it was a
style thing people were sitting in
dresses for portraits there's one thing
she'll never have
boots that go up to her knees
they don't make them no they do not make
them possible
one thing she'll never wear flood pants
that's right
they just become knickers yeah
with a k
yes not a k to be clear
god this is where we are right now let
me know do we have do we have a giuliani
is here is he ready to go not yet all
right
well i don't necessarily know if he's
known for punctuality qriket wireless
takes a minute let's take a q well i was
going to say today we usually do this
behind the pillow can we take a couple
of chats really quickly is there
anything else that i'm missing here is
there any anything new and developing i
hope that i've covered all the bases for
you again all references are available
at loudercredit.com we usually have the
link in the description
because i think this is an important day
where you should be i would recommend
that you read all of these sources that
we have today yeah i think it's really
important well that's what they said
there's nothing that they're going after
i'm sorry joe no i just have a quick
question so i i think everybody right
now is demanding a response from the fbi
yeah do you think merrick garland comes
out today and tries to to quell this a
little bit because the the the heat from
this already today is crazy they feel
that they're above the law yeah so your
answer is no
i don't know maybe he will but he's not
going to answer it yeah and who's the
only person that's above the law
mr seagal it's right there
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i hope he comes out and just gets pied
in the face
that would be a great pressure
relief right now wouldn't it oh i love
it wouldn't that improve your day just a
little bit oh it wouldn't do improve my
day 100 especially if they got pied and
before they tackled them we had like
enough time to twist it
just for sure
make it stick like a bozo show gag well
that happened to our prime minister in
canada like nine times really yeah prime
minister doesn't get assassinated he
gets pied
it's worse we also had a guy trying to
shoe polish with judah
he was trying to hide what happened
with the prime minister yeah not with
trudeau but with other prime ministers
uh and there was actually an
assassination attempt i can't remember
who was stephen harper if it was [ __ ]
where the guy
got into the prime minister's house
mansion yeah
didn't even bring a weapon
so he like grabbed
he grabbed cutlery from their own
kitchen i was like i guess i should have
thought this through yeah got up to the
bedroom or at all the wife saw him and
closed the door
[Laughter]
and she's calling she's like hey hello
ring ring security this guy's here yeah
he's using my he's using my knives no he
doesn't have a pie
yeah that's much much what kind of
knives are they oh they're not like
ginsu or anything they're just butter
knives yeah it's it's just i don't know
i think he got them from our plastics
tim hortons leftover drawer yeah
and if he tries really hard he might
scratch the door yes
but can you come up anyway
maybe do your job
that actually happened in canada it's a
silly silly place so when people talk
about oh america you're saying we have
socialized healthcare it's because
you're a silly country that's
inconsequential it doesn't matter and
they do surgery with tim horton's knives
yes they do they don't let a good knife
go to waste dave no well they sterilize
them they clean them they use them twice
oh wait a second right now they are
talking on cnn before we go to julia and
if we don't get giuliana here soon then
we can just go and take chat we're going
to do some extensive chat with you today
uh former secretary of state mike so um
let's see what they're saying they've
really wanted to get to the bottom to
with some of these high-ranking
officials who frankly you know had a lot
of concern after what they saw on
january 6. you know we know that a
handful of high-ranking officials have
talked about sleight of hand right now
yeah oh look january 6th january 6th huh
it's like a like a photographer with a
rattle for a baby huh huh see the
january 6th see the january 6th uh hold
on a second does it have anything to do
with it
you went there was classified is this
the january 6th thing yeah january 6th
january 6th come on look over here
january 6th right about rattle
she looks like she should be reporting
from a black leather sofa yes she does
doesn't she she usually does
they told her it was unprofessional
just please inform us courtney loves
doug thank you so much for that it's
back with me now caitlyn connolly thank
you
and cnn's dana bash dana focusing in on
the trump cabinet and as sarah was
laying out specifically on the
conversations around the 25th minute
what do you what does that tell you
about where the committee
is
what path the committee is headed down
now this is why we have this here just
so you know a lot of shows out either
they do live programs where it's just
people talking
or they pre-tape these kinds of programs
and by the way we know this because
we've spoken with people at youtube
extensively
they recommend that we don't go live
they don't want you to go live because
it's risky right nothing up our sleeve
that's why we have cnn up here we don't
pre-tape these things the only things we
ever pre-taped sometimes are ash
wednesdays that's the only thing we
pre-tape now is the sketches things
because we want you to experience this
with us right now live
do you see what's happening right now
go look at go go look at your facebook
your instagram your twitter go talk to
your friends go out into the real world
discuss with your social circle see if
they're discussing
pompeo testifying before the january 6th
committee or the raid the unprecedented
fbi raid
on president trump's house
we've always wanted to think that
there's someone who knows what they're
talking about in media people used to
think like walter cronkite no it was
always horse [ __ ]
they're not giving you news that you
need to know they are always selecting
news that they want you to hear that's
what they do that's their job they're
incapable of anything else
so just let this sink in there has never
been an unbiased media there has never
been unbiased journalism in this country
we all like to think that there's some
experts sitting there going like this is
something that americans have to know
that's never been the case they say how
do we want to craft it just like a
political campaign all right i believe
we have
we have uh
america's mayor coming up here we have
rudy giuliani in the line
[Music]
who's that all right there you are mr
julie how do you prefer to be referred
to uh mr giuliani you prefer mayor you
prefer
rudy well
mayor giuliani she likes mayor giuliani
and i like ruth okay i just heard him
say mayor giuliani i don't want to say
rudy because then gerald's going to get
all aroused he went to notre dame and
think of that crappy film or the guy
didn't deserve to be in the field
like my mother did there you go oh did
she do that when you were in trouble
no no she called me that all the time
that's what i named you and that's what
i'm gonna call you well that's that's
actually was a distinct name until that
little prick reindeer had to ruin it for
the rest of you so they
made my kindergarten very tough i can
imagine yeah just ask blitzen now mayor
giuliani um you're in the same office i
believe one time when we one of the the
the times you were a guest on this
program and we last spoke and by the way
people can of course you can listen to
his podcast at uh giuliani's common
sense you can listen to where her
podcasts are you can follow him on
twitter at rudy giuliani
okay there you go because i i didn't
want to say mayor giuliani and then get
the plug wrong um
let me first ask you something before we
get to you having been raided this is
why i want to have you on because you
have firsthand experience
uh is this unprecedented
army is this unprecedented what they've
done with uh uh unbel un
incredibly unprecedented in many
different ways
first of all it's the first time that a
president
has authorized and of course his
administration a
criminal action against his predecessor
right i mean we've had a couple of
centuries of history and we've avoided
the practice in banana republics and
fascist days
of uh the practice of putting your
predecessor in prison
and uh this is the first time any
president has ever done that i mean even
even when trump was confronted with lock
her up lock her up lock her up every
place he went he never
never restarted the criminal case
against hillary clinton right and she
wasn't president she was just not
sleeping with him
but i mean she was the secretary of
state and the wife of the president and
his president and his opponent
so
uh we're breaking an unwritten rule
that has kept us a democracy
and kept us a different than a fascist
state also you can't see this in a
vacuum right they've been hounding him
for uh they've been trying to frame him
for a crime for seven years yes they're
not able to articulate what this crime
is
this is some kind of alleged record
violation yeah they said mishandling of
classified information i want to make
sure the audience hears it from you
a a former you know a former president
right just to be clear of course many
former presidents still have access to
classified information the media has
tried to imply that that is somehow
illegal it's not their claim is that he
wasn't handling it properly right
which i would imagine every single
president
putting together a presidential library
makes that mistake a hundred times yes
this is this this has never been pursued
criminally ever before
this is again one of these things where
they
never have pursued anyone criminally but
trump people
i mean the same thing was true with the
foreign corrupt practices act until they
got to manafort
people got to pay fines for them right
manafort went to jail was put in
solitary confinement for doing something
that had
just about never been prosecuted
criminally here's the real issue they've
investigated this man for seven years
and they can't find a real crime right
a crime that you and i would relate to
as like stealing money like biden did
like taking bribes right like uh like uh
carrying carrying around a 38 revolver
when you're a drug addict which is a
10-year felony and throwing it in a
trash can by a school that's a real
crime yeah uh
being involved in a 3.1 million dollar
money wandering transaction whereby on
record gets eight hundred thousand
dollars when he's the vice president of
the united states that's called bribery
that's a real crime i can call i can i
can describe those crimes this is
a dispute
over records are classified or not or
who gets to classify whether they're
presidential
the reality is he could
by taking him from the white house that
that mere act alone could declassify all
these pages right the president gets to
classify and declassify it right when he
ordered their removal he was the
president
yeah number two they stayed
the fbi padlocked this room a few weeks
ago
they just went and broke the padlock
they put there
they lost the key
just like flowers
who lost a hard drive i know that i i
sent out a tweet i said if you want a
hard drive i got a couple extra copies
right
and i tried to give it to you when you
raided my house and you didn't want it
now they lost the hard drive
they went there a few weeks ago they
searched the whole place
they saw everything
they said it wasn't secure enough
so they put in an additional padlock
their own yeah and when they came in
they didn't bring the key for it so they
had to crack it open they looked and
they took the same things they looked at
a couple of weeks ago well to be fair it
may not have been secured well enough if
the fbi uh were in fact the ones
securing it you know they probably just
that's absolutely that's absolutely like
a gym school luck yeah let's just put
that on there for the pro let's call it
a day and by the way hillary clinton
didn't just take documents she took the
ws off the keyboard when they were
leaving which is kind of funny it is
kind of funny
it's a combination one of them just
forgot the five yes exactly
so it is unprecedented and it's a very
very
damaging thing to do i mean we're just
about at the end of really saying we
have a fair system of justice
i think we are at the end standards we
have two standards this uh i mean
we've had for five years outstanding
criminal cases against the bidens yeah
not not just the son and the president
but the brother none of them have been
raided none of them have been
searched none of them have been
brought before a grand jury none of them
been arrested
right meanwhile
the trump people get searched
and then they don't find anything well
here's my question because they haven't
apologized for me
well i wouldn't i wouldn't uh hold your
breath for that but let me ask you this
you on this program actually was the
first time the public saw the hunter
biden laptop and then we had you back on
when the fbi raided
your you know your uh your private
offices they didn't take that laptop
what what did they take
they took they took all of the
electronics in my
house okay and all the electronics and
this is the really a constitutional
violation in my law office ah yeah much
of which didn't relate to donald trump
of course that is a gross violation of
the sixth amendment
yeah uh and the only lawyers who get
searched are trump lawyers i never
searched a lawyer when i was in the
justice department no i always thought
there was a sixth amendment called
attorney-client privilege well biden has
done away with that no attorney-client
approvers for trump think about that
double standard people searched here and
they searched my law office yeah think
about that they returned everything to
me
right i have everything back
because
as i told them then
have me come in and ask me questions and
i'll answer them they took a year and a
half to say yes to that
i finally went in i spent four hours
with him and
i what i told them at the beginning is
true i'm not stupid i don't commit
crimes right i was a us attorney for 17
years
i know what crimes are and what they're
now now you're going to go make up
crimes on me i can't do much about that
right but i don't commit crimes i just
don't well think of the double standard
you have republicans you have
conservatives out there and this is what
we're talking about i mean for crying
out loud dinesh d'souza had to wear an
ankle bracelet because he gave money to
a friend's campaign beyond the maximum
allowable amount who lost just to be
clear again these are things where
usually someone gets fined and if you're
a democrat you don't get fined but think
about this you're talking about attorney
client privilege and it's something that
i know very well conservatives
republicans out there right now are
afraid
to even keep notes or what they discuss
with their lawyer because even though
it's their constitutional right their
concerns that that could be raided
meanwhile hunter
and ashley biden leave a paper trail
longer than a circuit city receipt of
every misdeed they've committed because
there's no fear of retribution
whatsoever they'll walk right past the
hard drive in your office to grab [ __ ]
they have no right to grab from you
pardon my language
right and they go out and say
i never spoke to any of my son's foreign
clients and there are 17 uh
pieces of evidence of 17 different
meetings with foreign clients including
chinese communists with joe biden when
he was the vice president
disgustingly selling his office
this guy got 31 million dollars from
china i know china's our enemy that's
not a national security problem and a
couple of papers sitting behind padlocks
in mar-a-lago that nobody even knows
what they are what kind of national
security could they be right well to be
fair also too joe biden was just uh he
was loaning his office to eric swellwell
for his uh practices with the the
chinese spies look
i want to and we'll actually talk about
that he actually went after me on
twitter eric swalwell think about this
like you're talking i'm going what
wormhole did i fall into where eric
swalwell has anything from him or or his
chinese communicators
well i don't know she could be running
his social media at this point i think
he's dating a russian spy now um yeah
he's actually more of a patriot yes
she's more of a patriot than eric's wall
well we're going to go here uh because i
want to ask you about next steps um to
mug club so we're not on youtube so that
we don't need to worry about any hot
water again uh the twitter is at rudy
giuliani and the podcast is let me make
sure i get this right i want to make
sure i read everything correctly it is
rudy giuliani's common sense uh
right now youtube thank you so much this
is a day that is going to live in infamy
and i'm no longer comfortable discussing
this with you we'll take some of your
questions here for
america's mayor mary giuliani youtube
piss off
[Music]
bye